- WELL, I DO HAVE
THIS NEANDERTHAL JAW HERE,
SO I'M GONNA GO WITH I'M A SIX.
- WELL, YOU'RE TOO SKINNY.
I THINK YOU COULD BE A SEVEN
IF YOU WEREN'T SO SKINNY.
'CAUSE, LIKE,
GIRLS LOVE A LITTLE SQUISH.
REMINDS 'EM OF THEIR DADS.
- YEAH.
- YOU KNOW? AND ALL GIRLS
WANNA BANG THEIR DADS.
BUT THEY CAN'T
BECAUSE OF LAWS AND STUFF.
- I'M AN 11,
'CAUSE I GOT A SIX UP HERE,
AND A FIVE-INCH PORK SWORD,
SO...
- OH...
[laughter]
- OH! HEY, HEY!
[honks horn]
- GET OUTTA THE WAY!
- LET'S GO, BABAK.
- WE'RE TRYING
TO GET SOME DOUGHNUTS, MAN!
- [laughs]
OOH, THEY FEISTY TODAY.
- HEY, GET THIS HOOPTY
OFF MY COURT.
- ARE YOU TELLING ME
YOU CONDONE OF THIS? AND THAT?
- YEAH, WELL,
CORPORATE'S BEEN BUGGING ME
TO START A "HEALTH INITIATIVE."
SO INSTEAD OF RUNNING
SOME STUPID 5K,
WHICH WOULD KILL
HALF OF THESE SLOBS,
WE'RE HAVING
A 3-ON-3 TOURNAMENT.
- OH, VERY COOL.
I DID NOT KNOW
YOU BALLED, ALICE.
- YEAH, WELL, IT'S IN MY BLOOD.
MY DAD WORKED FOR
THE CHICAGO BULLS GROWING UP.
- MY GOSH. THAT WOULD BE,
LIKE, A DREAM GIG.
- DID HE PARTY
WITH B.J. ARMSTRONG?
- DID HE AND B.J., LIKE, GET BJs
TOGETHER IN THE LOCKER ROOM?
THAT'D BE COOL, RIGHT?
- [laughs] YEAH.
- ARE YOU ASKING ME
IF MY DAD GOT A [bleep]JOB
NEXT TO AN NBA PLAYER
IN A BATHROOM
AND THEN TOLD ME ABOUT IT?
- OH, IT'S INAPPROPRIATE?
- YEAH, A LITTLE BIT.
- OH, SORRY, THERE'S DIFFERENT
SOCIAL STANDARDS
IN DIFFERENT SITUATIONS.
- YEAH.
- EW.
ANYWAY, I DID GET CORPORATE
TO PUT UP A COOL-ASS PRIZE.
[clicks tongue]
- OH! OH! IS THAT A DODGE DART?
OH! [laughs]
I FREAKIN' LOVE DODGE DARTS.
- GREAT SAFETY RATINGS.
- THAT IS MY FAVORITE CAR,
AND I'M ASKING FOR THAT
FOR, LIKE, THE NEXT SIX
CHRISTMASES FROM MY PARENTS.
- NO. NO, NO, NO,
YOU DON'T WIN THE CAR.
NO, THAT'S THE COMPANY CAR.
BUT YOU DO GET TO DRIVE IT
FOR A TWO-DAY ONE-NIGHT STAY
AT ONE OF
THE T.A.C. TIMESHARES IN RENO!
- SO WE DO GET TO DRIVE
THE DODGE DART.
- YEAH.
- SO WE DO GET TO BE
IN THE DODGE DART.
- TO THE BIG DIRTY, BABY.
- TO RENO, TO RENO.
I THINK RENO IS THE NEW VEGAS.
INSTEAD OF, LIKE,
BEING THE RAT PACK,
WE COULD BE, LIKE,
THE FRAT PACK, DUDE.
I CALL SETH ROGEN.
- I'LL BE ANY WILSON BROTHER.
- ANYWAY, YOU'RE PLAYING
WAYMOND, BILL, AND BABAK
AFTER LUNCH.
- OH. COUPLE OF LOSERS!
WHERE THEY AT?
- 'CAUSE WAYMOND,
YOU'RE GOING DOWN!
- WATCH THIS.
HEY, GUYS. HEY, GUYS.
- DON'T HAVE SEX
WITH THE DODGE DART.
- I'M GONNA DUNK OFF THE VOLVO!
- HEY, DUDE--
- WATCH THE SUNROOF.
all: OH!
- DUDE!
- [laughs]
- AND ONE...
OF MY NUTS JUST RUPTURED.
- WHAT AN IDIOT.
- IT'S OUT OF THE POUCH.